hi everybody welcome back to the gadget
lab i am michael colorae and i'm nathan
olivares giles and we were out last week
because we were in las vegas
at the consumer electronics show
along with everybody else in the gadget
lab and uh we had a good time yeah it
was fun you know it's fun to see like
all of these other journalists you don't
get to see too often what all these you
know new companies uh have to show off
and what all the same old same old guys
big tvs big tvs big tvs big tvs with big
resolutions big tvs but yeah your point
about the big companies and the small
companies i think that was probably the
biggest trend this year uh you know the
the days of
ces being ruled by you know the giant
apple and microsoft and yeah sony and
all that stuff has kind of fallen by the
wayside yeah microsoft didn't even show
up in the past they've been the big big
keynote this year was qualcomm which you
know was different um but a lot a lot of
the cool stuff that we saw was actually
from like kickstarter funded projects um
you know small startups or even folks
who've been around in the background
like nvidia they've been making you know
graphics processors for a long time now
they're making some video game hardware
yeah they made a really cool uh what's
it called the shield the shield yeah
it's an android like sort of an xbox
controller with an android screen on it
you got it that was one of the coolest
things i that i saw um but there was all
sorts of neat stuff from folks you just
wouldn't expect yeah and also you know a
lot of really small players are now able
to get into the game because of things
like kickstarter and india go go and
and um you know crowdfunding
uh projects like that and we saw a lot
of those we also saw a lot of um really
interesting
uh
uh cross-branded uh headphones like we
saw lemmy's headphones lemmy from
motorhead
and of course you know 50 cent dr dre
the same old players sorry that's the
camera that's whistling at us
we'll get to that later um you actually
interviewed uh fifth curtis fiddy i did
talk to 50 cent yeah that was one of the
most interesting interviews that i've
done
in my career thus far he was just a
really smart guy and pretty frank about
you know the quality of of his
headphones versus you know like the
audiophile stuff he's not making that
he's just kind of making what he thinks
is
something that can be profitable and
stylish and and sound good for the
youtube generation of music listeners
yeah and it's definitely something
different than what everybody else is
totally different he actually like has
an emphasis on
durability you can twist the heck out of
his headphones and they won't break
everybody has that now really yeah okay
but he bought the company right he did a
big thing he owns his company he's not
just not just licensing deal he owns it
yeah
it's his stuff well good for him i'm
glad to see him uh getting out of the
game and getting into the new game i
like it as they say yeah i have no idea
what they say come on uh anyway one of
the one of the crazy trends that we saw
is a lot of hybrid devices tablets that
are also this and gaming devices that
are also that and this is one of the
weirder ones we've come across recently
i say weird just because
it's unexpected tell us about this thing
it's a camera yeah so this is the
samsung galaxy camera and what it is is
it's basically um a 16 megapixel camera
with a 4.8 inch 720p touchscreen on the
back and it runs full android jelly bean
so you can not only take a you know
picture but then you can upload it to
instagram you can share it on facebook
or google plus you can surf the web you
can check your email so it has the guts
of an android phone it really is like an
android phone with a big
fat lens on the top of it which is just
bizarre yeah and it's kind of heavy um
but that being said you can't actually
make a phone call it runs on either
verizon or att's you know 4g 3g networks
but you can actually make a phone call
on it which is
almost kind of a bummer because you if
you want it to be the one device you
carry around it can't be because you
can't you can't go on it but does
everything else an android phone does
you know so it runs like touchwiz it
runs touchwiz so you still get like all
the little water droplet sound effects
um and you have you know samsung's
widgets here and stuff like that so if
you're used to samsung products you're
really gonna probably feel it at home
here um and it sells for about 550 bucks
but that's a lot of money it's a lot of
money especially considering that the
photo quality is probably around like
the 200 300 point shoot range in my
opinion interesting um so it's not the
best camera but it's the first you know
full android camera that i've seen like
this so it's sort of about the same
quality camera that you'd get well the
16 megapixel sensor right 16 megapixel
sensor so it's better than your
smartphone yeah and and it's you know
like an entry-level point-and-shoot
but you know it's obviously not going to
be like a high-end point-and-shoot it's
got a nice big zoom lens on it yeah yeah
you can do um up to 21 uh time uh
optical zoom yeah so it's like really
you know really high zoom but so you
know it's around the same quality you'd
get out of one of those super zooms from
like the cyber shot line from sony or
the power shot line from from canon yes
exactly around there yeah but it's just
got this giant
android phone it's the weirdest thing we
were playing with it and i'm watching
nate like kill spam
and you know look at yelp and play angry
birds
yeah and it's like you know it's like
watching him play with a galaxy note or
something like that but no it's a camera
yeah and with a 4.8 inch screen on the
back it feels kind of galaxy notice and
it's it's heavy too you know so the big
advantage is obviously sharing and does
it actually make it easier to facilitate
that does it make sharing things on the
internet yes
because now you don't have to pull out
your little micro sd card put it in your
laptop then share it to dropbox or to
facebook or to instagram you can just do
it here from this one device right so if
that's all you're into cool but if you
really you know
like our care about the quality of your
images then you could probably spend
your five 600 bucks better somewhere
else i would think so um i know you're
you're our android guy but have you
spent much time playing with like uh
iphone 5 with icloud and shared photo
streams and all that oh yeah oh yeah
yeah i mean i've i i
i'm always comparing you know what the
iphone's doing to what the latest
androids are doing and how do the how
does that experience
to the automatically pushing things to
the cloud compared to that it's
basically the same experience you take a
photo and it shows up in your dropbox
you don't have to think about it you
take a photo it can automatically show
up in google play you don't have to
think about it except the one thing you
can't do
make a phone call
that's the one thing you can't do yeah
yeah yeah but no it's great this kind of
feels like the the future of consumer
cameras you know there's still a lot of
rough edges there's still a lot of
quirks it's still weird but i think
we're going to see a lot more of this
kind of stuff showing up here down the
road and samsung's going to continue to
make the weird cutting edge things until
the end of time yeah they have so much
money and they're so big that they can
make anything they want if it fails no
big deal they'll be all right there'll
be another one
um so you're going to do a hands-on with
this you got it and then a full review
which you can read on wired.com and also
i'd recommend that you definitely go to
the gadget lab website on wired and look
at all of our ces coverage if you
haven't already
including our best of ces roundup that
will be live this week and
we will be back next week with more
wacky hybrid devices from the gadget lab